hello I'm Xena but are we welcome to the
concert hall in Stockholm where this
year's Nobel Prize winners received
their awards from the king of Sweden
this is in recognition of their
outstanding contributions to science and
economics which have brought great
benefits to humankind
and this is the first time that they are
appearing together in discussion on TV
here on noble minds and they're joined
in the audience by some of their family
and friends as well as students from
across Sweden
[Music]
well Nobel laureates ringing applause
and richly deserved it's been quite a
hectic week I think for all of you and
just give me some of your highlights
professor Donna Strickland well I'm the
one who had the privilege of sitting
beside its Majesty the King of Sweden
for the banquet and it was thrilling for
me and he was just so much fun and we
had a great time having a conversation
and you talked about girls just want to
have fun in your speech so advance seems
to be the watchword that's right
professor what would highlight you know
it was the last night you know when we
were really having exceptions about at
the palace and it was really amazing
city stables and so on and I was I had
the privilege to sit next to princess
Crown Princess Victoria yeah and we're
going quite discussions about about
everything so mixing with the Royals a
high-low field is something you don't do
many often professor or the same with me
I had a lots of interesting conversation
so I really enjoyed last night so it
sounds like the banquet so far has been
the highlight was it for you professor
Francis Arnold well I have to admit the
banquet was really quite special but
coming from Southern California I have
to say snow it's the night of the
ceremony and that was just beautiful Jim
Allison for me the most special was when
after the king presented the medal I
looked out for my family was sitting and
and so my wife and son might be tears
over ice and you got your bowels right
yeah I got all my Bowser quiet you tried
to proceed you yes George Smith well I
hate to be a party pooper but actually
frankly I think the highlight was the
Nobel lecture it's the thing that will
last on as the memories of this
celebration begin to fade
sibel Nordhaus the highlight for me was
to bring my grandchildren here my grand
that my granddaughter's and to bring to
the banquet and then when they were
interviewed by the news that they were
asked was it too long and they said no
it was too short
oh because they're quite young aren't
they and their mother was teaching them
how to sit up front yes but not around
but all the adults were getting tired
and they were just beginning to get ribs
all of these parts were wonderful I
liked getting to know a few people here
in Sweden the Alexander who took our
pictures when we were doing the
portraits it was just fascinating to see
how he did his job I also loved getting
to know my driver who was a woman and
also a bodyguard and she's she's pretty
cool she's bad because I mean you really
are fated and celebrated aren't you so
driven around in your own personal limos
and so on well anyway well let's start
talking about why you want some of these
prizes and we're going to start with the
economists bill Nordhaus and Paul Romer
but let's just have a quick look at what
you want your prize ball by studying how
nature and knowledge are affected by
markets and economic behavior William
Nordhaus and Paul Romer designed
economic models that address some of
today's most fundamental and pressing
issues long-term sustainable growth in
the global economy and welfare of the
world's population
professor naught house has developed
tools that project the economic impacts
of climate change and provide approaches
for slowing its progress
professor Romo has explained how
knowledge and ideas can serve as engines
for long-term economic growth and why
government policies play a critical role
in fostering technological innovation
Paul Romer so just explain a bit more to
us about the link between innovation and
economic growth when people look back on
this time what are they going to
remember things like the discovery of
electric light of antibiotics the
transistor
maybe maybe cancer immunotherapy that
could be as big as antibiotics in the
long run those kinds of innovations just
make all the difference in the quality
of lives but they actually boost
economic growth they do and you know we
get we get income but we also get
quality of life that isn't always
measured in income the thing to remember
is that we need as a society to steer
the direction of innovation there's some
innovation that we don't want somebody
could find a way to get coal out of the
ground at very low cost we don't want
that kind of innovation what we want is
more of a say innovation that helps
reduce the cost of low carbon zero
carbon energy but you say it's going to
be steered so markets are not enough to
ensure that we have that no innovation
no the way to think of the market the
market works for us you know it's not
the boss the the we're the boss but
don't forget the things that work like
cities work there's a technology for
getting millions of people in a pretty
small area so just copy the parts about
cities intellectual property and all
that kind of thing and people putting up
you know protectionism think think of
intellectual property is as we always
give these two handed answers on the one
hand you could use intellectual property
but on the other hand you could use
science you subsidize the research and
you you give the results away you know
President Truman said you wanted a
one-armed economist because he was so
tired of on the one yeah but but but
it's still important to remember that
that system of science that we all
participated in is a very good way to
produce discoveries and get them out
into wide circulation bill
I mean your research looks at how the
causes and consequences of climate
change and what can be done in economics
to try to tackle climate change I mean
what does your research tell us about
what's doable that climate change is bad
for the economy and that tackling it is
good for the economy well I'll just
start where Paul Romer left off with
innovation so we often think of
innovations and inventions in terms of
the things my my friends who have done
but let's just it this wasn't this was
in it this ballpoint pen was actually
historic innovation in about 50 years
ago but these often we think of these
gadgets so to speak or more fundamental
ones but also there's a whole nother
class which are called institutional
inventions where we invent new
institutions and in this field I think
the most important invention would be a
fiscal system to steer the economy
whether it's a tax or another way of
raising the prices of carbon fuels this
will steer the economy but this this is
actually we think that's obvious but
actually this was an invention of an
institutional kind that has been made
over the last 60 or 70 years so you're
an advocate of carbon tax which just
basically makes the use of fossil fuels
dirty fossil fuels more expensive and
incentivizes producers and people
through government policies or subsidies
or whatever to try and turn to renewable
fuels but is that really doable in
practice what you economists may
determine is desirable is sometimes not
politically expedient is it well the
thing I would emphasize is not the
carbon tax but the carbon price that you
need to raise the price of co2 emissions
and thereby raise the price of fuels and
all the products that the fuels are
embodied in so it isn't just burning the
fuels but it will be body in our
electricity in our air travel in our
ballpoint pens so in in in proportion to
the amount and it doesn't have to be a
tax but does your research bill note
house actually
that it makes economic sense to tackle
climate change yeah you can do it and
have sustainable long-term growth so in
a broader framework what we know is that
the way we measure our output which is
the gross domestic product miss measures
it because it doesn't incorporate the
damages that are outside the market such
as health health is not included whether
we die early or die young
whether we're sick or healthy that is
not included in our economic
measurements so we when we include that
then we see we would actually have
higher incomes in this reals inclusive
comprehensive sense if we include
measures that reduce the damages well
it's not just climate change it's also
particulate from burning fuels and so on
a poor Roma
I mean you've worked as a chief
economist of the World Bank advising
governments and institutions and you
come from a political family your father
was a former Democratic governor in
became a scientist the politicians job
is too hard but it's always going to ask
you I mean so yeah but you economists
can say look it makes sense to do this
and to do that and we need to direct
market forces and so on and so forth as
you've been saying but it's not easy for
the politicians to always do know what
you think is right no I kind of like
Churchill's quote about the United
States is just applied to all humans
they always do what's right after
exhausting all the alternatives you just
have to be a little bit patient but just
staying with this idea of you know what
governments can do professor Melville
you live in Paris now and we've seen the
relation the process against President
macrons desire to have these green fuel
taxes which uses are in part to try to
combat global warming look at the
problem societies abandoned the idea
absolutely this guy's no is trying Harry
to do something innovative is trying to
push people ready to save I mean there's
no way we are going to to keep this this
style of living you know I stand up we
have to do something we really have to
do something and and we have to
introduce some incentives to do it so I
think your taxes and not only
columnist okay but I understand that
maybe the taxon is the only way to put
some pressure on the people and say hey
you know you you have to reduce your
consumption so how would you recommend
that we we avoid the yellow jersey
movement in if we raise the if the price
of a carbon is raised because it hurts
people well I think the first thing is
you make it comprehensive rather than
focusing on fuel and that's actually the
most politically insensitive tax in the
world is a gasoline tax or a fuel tax
you make it comprehensive if you make it
comprehensive it's more like a
value-added tax it gets built into the
chain of production and then the other
things you start at a low level and you
build it up gradually you need not to
have the only to have the tax but you
need to have the institutions you have
you have to have people who can accept
this and realize it's part of our system
is part of the solution so I think just
hitting people trying to do it as a kind
of kind of shock therapy is actually
politically the wrong way you need to
start small start comprehensive start
universally across countries and build
up gradually from there jump in I think
partly start small big government
programs often almost always start small
and get bigger the other thing is we
need to have the whole machinery of
carbon taxes ready we need to talk about
it but then at some point there'll be
some huge hurricane some huge fire
something that becomes a crisis and then
all of a sudden politicians are going to
say what are we gonna do and if we've
done all of our homework then they'll
say okay that's it let's do it
anybody else want to come in on this
well do the raising the the price of
these fuels and materials is critical I
think but another way to come at the
problem is to invent new technologies
and lower the cost of the alternatives
so that's where scientists like us can
contribute we can invent those and
improve on those technologies and at the
same time then we're joining forces with
the institutions that you create that
will bring the same
to chemistry because Francis Arnold you
awarded half of the prize in part for
finding green solutions to some of the
world's problems like climate change in
the Sun so let's just see what the
chemistry laureates won their prize for
and then we'll pick that up
inspired by the power of evolution
Francis Arnaud develops new biological
material in the form of enzymes
catalysts that accelerates chemical
reactions her work is currently being
used in the environmentally friendly
manufacturing of pharmaceuticals and the
production of renewable fuels George
Smith was studying the biology of
viruses that infect bacteria known as
phages when he conceived a way of
evolving the viruses to generate new
molecules with desirable properties an
essential part of all living organisms
Gregg winter then harnessed this
technique to create new antibodies
immune proteins that attack bacteria and
viruses the work of George Smith and
Gregg winter has successfully been used
to combat autoimmune and inflammatory
bowel diseases and metastatic cancer so
Francis Arnold as we saw just that your
work has led to a multitude of potential
uses and what exactly is it being used
to develop do you know well chemistry of
the biological world is is amazing
biology is the best chemist on the
planet because she knows how to take
abundant renewable resources and convert
them into an array of chemicals and
materials some of which we've used for
hundreds of years thousands of years
imagine if we could use biology to make
most of the things we need including
fuels or agents that can be used for
crop control these things are happening
now you've made institutions that will
make that possible by having the the
price reflect the true cost of many of
these products but we are inventing the
technologies that will
make that possible I used evolution to
do it evolution has made everything in
the biological world until today and it
can help us move forward so I breed
molecules like you breed cats and dogs
and and I mean give us an idea of what
your work could really open up in terms
of its potential uses well the little
workhorses of life that do all this
chemistry are called enzymes you have
them in your laundry detergents your
consumer products they make your blue
jeans look nice many of the things that
you use in your daily lives are
developed with enzymes I make them
better than what nature did for human
purposes so for example we as several
students and I started a company about
15 years ago that makes renewable jet
fuel for airplanes comes from plant
materials agricultural waste products or
trees for example that you can use then
to take those sugars and make jet fuels
a biofuel with biofuels that's one of
the examples and there many other exams
and also for example the production of
pharmaceuticals
you've also that can be used to detoxify
the process as it were all sorts of
applications you can replace toxic
chemical processes that use expensive
metals for example that are
environmentally hugely unfriendly to
mine you can replace all those with
clean biological processes I like to say
you replace chemists with bacteria
you're actually mechanical engineer onto
by training did you always have a very
clear vision of the kinds of paths and
what you wanted to achieve well in some
ways yes I was always interested in
doing something that would help humans
and the planet I think it's a pretty
nice planet that we live on and I'd like
to see much of the natural world as
possible be conserved we won't do that
if we don't learn how to make what we
need in our daily lives in a much more
efficient way how you did that
I had to figure that out through a
meandering path which eventually brought
me to evolution you know to describe to
my students what a wonderful world we
live in I used to tell him think of the
cow as the best chemical refinery you
could ever build you know like it takes
renewable resources it makes milk it
builds a new one when it wears out you
know it's like well we could we can make
that we can make something like a cow
out of just atoms I mean who'd a thunk
or a yeast that takes sugar and makes
alcohol milk and alcohol so George
Smith's just staying with the chemistry
prize you were studying the biology of
viruses that infect bacteria and worked
with phages as phage display and so on
as we thought so just explain a bit more
to us it's a way of creating a huge
amount of variety of structures and a
way of an investigator choosing a goal
and selecting from that huge array of
structures the few that can meet that
goal this is evolution up and down this
is what evolution does it it doesn't
have a goal in mind but if we mimic it
in laboratory we ourselves can have a
goal in mind and no idea in detail how
that goal can be achieved phage display
your work on that which really allows us
to generate human antibodies was then
built upon by Sir Gregory winter who is
not with us in this discussion but he
used that and it went quite a way to
helping tackle rheumatoid arthritis and
metastatic cancer so you know something
which has really been remarked on
greatly I wonder if you would just
mention that link there Greg mentioned
libraries of a hundred billion
structures selecting from among those
the rare ones that we'll meet meet a
goal so the goal in that case was
antibodies that would be fully human
could be used in therapy without
provoking an immune reaction against the
antibody
themselves because they come from a
foreign source like a mouse
so Greg set out to create a library of
human antibodies artificially a huge
huge libraries and and devised a way of
selecting those that would have a
specificity for a desired target that
has therapeutic importance okay I just
draw the link to the literature prize
which was unawarded this year or he's
has this famous story the the library of
Babel do you know yes yeah I mean what
you're describing is really just like
what Porky's describes in the water
who's that in my Nobel lecture nearly
infinite set of possibilities and what
the phage display does and and to lesser
extent what enzyme evolution does is
give you a way to search through that
library that Bohr Hayes didn't have that
way to do it but evolution can take us
through that infinite set of
possibilities to find the ones that are
useful for life and for us and if you
think if we keep looking for a vaccine
for malaria do you think we'll find it
because we've only explored a few a very
small part of the space well maybe you
would fund my grants you can do
professor Smith make your pitch why not
your television well I'm retired now so
I'm not searching for grants but yes
it's specifically the approach that I
had suggested was a way of finding many
more vaccine candidates so that we
didn't depend on 10 or 12 but perhaps on
200 candidates that would have a pretty
good starting chance of meeting the goal
of a vaccine it seems that a vaccine
should be possible
you've all harnessed the power of them
evolution in your work and we've talked
about cancer which remarkably it's the
first time that a Nobel Prize has been
awarded for advancements in the
treatment of cancer the medicine or
physiology laureates will come to you in
a moment but let's just look at what you
won the prize for James Allison and
tasuku hangzhou discovered how to
unleash the body's immune system to
attack cancer cells
James Allison identified a protein that
acts as a brake on the immune system and
realized that by reversing it the system
would be able to attack cancer cells
independently tasuku hangzhou discovered
another protein which also operates as a
brake on the immune system but with a
different mechanism it's the first time
the development of a cancer treatment
has been acknowledged with a Nobel Prize
Professor Jim Allison so did you set
about trying to find a cure for cancer
no not really I was trying to understand
the function of T cells which are a
product of evolution and ultimately that
ourselves to go off throughout your body
looking for things that oughtn't to be
there and we've developed this system of
cells a way of making receptors on them
that can recognize nobody knows how many
different things these cells are a type
of white blood cells white blood cells
that have antigen receptors on them
they're called it could recognize almost
anything that Nature throws at you
because they create in your body or
libraries such as
we've heard about it - consisting of
probably you have not as big as some of
these libraries you've probably got
somewhere between 70 and 100 million
different T cells in your body that can
recognize almost anything so you set
about trying to understand the immune
system exactly we found that there was a
molecule called ctla4 anyway that was
the brakes on that system and it what's
a large part of what it doesn't stop T
cells from proliferating and one of the
ideas that I had was for some other
ideas after we figured that out was that
maybe the reason that the immune system
isn't so good at attacking cancer is
because it stops the T cells before you
have enough to kill all the tumor cells
and so if we just disabled the brakes
for a time we could let them keep going
until they you know eliminated all the
cancer cells and so that was the idea
pretty far-fetched because at the time
everybody thought that T cells divide
then they die it's not that this is an
active mechanism whose job tells us he
cells to stop it so that was your work
but what about You professor tasks you
Han Joe I mean you were working
independently and also discovered how to
kind of release the break in the immune
system which stops it from attacking
cancer cells but did you set about
trying to just understand how the immune
system works better or did you think
yourself some treatment for cancer would
be a really good ambition well in bottom
had my heart because I'm a medical
doctors originally I wanted to have some
hope to cure the cancer or any diseases
but when I started working the pd-1 it
was a just molecule we accidentally
identified starting the t-cell selection
or a regulation of that Tisa or gain but
when we found this is a different break
than Jim just mentioned and why immune
system is working so well against the
cancer because cancer just accumulate
mutations they become different from the
our body so that's what
reason why we can attack Professor Andre
I mean there are hundreds of types of
different cancers yes so when we talk
about treating cancer or curing cancer
can can we actually cure cancer and can
we cure all sorts of cancers or we just
talking about some specific ones well at
this moment there are several cancers
which we can cure some which very
difficult there are several reasons one
is the immune system cannot approach to
the site where the tumor is located some
cancers do not express so many different
molecule normal cells mean the mutation
rate is low so at this stage we can say
we conquer the cancer it's just
beginning of the whole story so we need
lots of research professor Jim Allison I
know that you personally have had a lot
of experience with cancer you yourself
have had three types accounts so you
lost your mother at the age of 10 to
cancer her brother uncle's cousin and so
it's it's something that you you know
have experienced firsthand but I want to
bring him one of your patients who were
suffering for a melanoma Sharon Belvin
who's traveled all the way to Sweden to
be with you at the celebrations of the
Nobel Prize and Sharon Belvin I wonder
so give us your story because you've
been suffering from all you had cancer
what what happened so I was 22 just out
of grad school and I found out that I
had Stage four melanoma so lungs lymph
nodes and brain pretty much as I was
filed I didn't even know what life was
like at that time every single
conventional therapy for melanoma like
dr. Allison said I mean not very
effective it was a death sentence at the
time we tried it all until I was offered
a clinical trial for an immunotherapy
and it worked
textbook I got one round of treatment
and I have been in remission ever since
I was diagnosed in 2004 in remission
since 2000
six 2018 that must be very important to
you that so yeah yeah it's good at first
that happened on this chant only it
she's tumor-free I I don't know I cried
a lot along the way they along with her
and uh that was 14 years ago and well
let's enter the physics prize because
that's also had some medical
applications and professor Donna
Strickland and sure are no we were along
with Arthur Ashkan who couldn't be with
us and he's in fact the oldest Nobel
Prize recipient at 96 by some measure
for the moment but let's just look at
what you won the prize for Gerard mu and
Donna Strickland paved the way for the
highest intensity laser beams ever
created their optical pulse technique is
now used in millions of corrective eye
surgeries every year and in many other
industrial and medical applications
Arthur Ashkan created optical tweezers
precision tools that enable scientists
to grab tiny living cells in laser beams
without harming them his work has
transformed the way researchers are able
to study microscopic life so Donna
Strickland along with your supervisor
shyamu turn the tables maybe
uuugh one half of the prize Donna
Strickland you said you saw your first
laser at the age of 10 and it was love
at first sight there are many societal
applications for your work but you're a
great advocate of science for science
sake aren't you why that's right I mean
there are now applications of what Jared
and I did but at the time we were trying
to do pretty basic atomic physics with
our laser and we also knew that when we
changed the laser intensity by orders of
magnitude it would change how light
interact with matter and but we couldn't
exactly tell how it would change but we
knew that it had
because we were going to be beating
those atoms to death so and then down
the road that leads to discovery and
innovation but my big thing is that we
have to remember to always try to push
for fundamental science because without
that twenty years down the road there
can't be more innovations if we don't
keep trying to understand the world at a
very small level you would agree with
that or is the most useful science the
best science
I'd say focus buddy and I think that in
my case it all came from basic science
to trying to understand how t cells
worked I think if somebody had just said
how we're gonna kill tumor cells they
would have found another way of pushing
on them but they wouldn't have
discovered that there's an important
it's important to take the breaks off
and then they'll they'll do their job I
take a slightly different view it's kind
of like this notion of diversity I think
you need a lot of different kinds of
activity some of which are very problem
focused some of which are very basics
base basic one of the things we say is
that thermodynamics did I sorry the
steam engine did more for thermodynamics
then thermodynamics did for the steam
engine so sometimes it's not the basic
science that comes first science of
science sake or the best science is the
most useful no I absolutely now I don't
believe that the best the best science
is the most useful I mean I I would
analogize innovation to the phages that
I work with which in fact promiscuously
in the the the cells that they that they
and that they affect in fact they can be
combined with each other make new
versions that go on to infect and I
think ideas intellectual progress is
like that as well the applied science
steals from the basic science all the
tools that we use in applied science to
solve a problem were developed by basic
scientists so that you cannot have one
without the other and basic science goes
backs and uses the new tools that come
along so it's not always the basic that
comes first
so I think it goes back into some donor
said I'm going to create a hundred
million dollar prize to come up with a
vaccine that's effective against malaria
would that be a bad thing I mean you're
talking about life science and this is
well you know I think we defer because
for me from the life life science it's
not really fundamental science back seat
for Blair you get a vaccine for malaria
maybe but you won't learn anything about
how to treat cancer you or anything okay
that's not true when Pasteur was trying
to solve the problem just how do you
carry food for the French army that
doesn't spoil he invents microbiology
what if not in evolution is a great
example no one knows how to design an
enzyme but evolution finds the solutions
and then we reverse engineer the
solutions that work in order to
understand the basic principles so in
that example you're exactly right we are
in a very primitive stage so we don't
know where the real goodies you know if
you know which direction you go you get
something great if that happens it's
great but at this stage I think all we
have to do is dig many places and
somebody hit the goal somebody hit
something and then I have to think I
just want to re-emphasize this in these
points in terms of science policy
because often there are the people who
paid arson for our science asked us to
do applied science they say what is the
application what is the use of this and
if you're doing something that isn't
obviously useful then it's more
difficult it's not just an individual
project but in terms of this whole
streams there
we need streams in different areas and
there's a there's a story that may or
may not be true but when Queen that
Toria visited Faraday in the laboratory
and said to him what is the use of
electricity and which is like a stunning
stunning question and he said madam
someday you will tax it which which may
or may not be true I'm fundamentally
difficult as all have you been saying to
forecast what direction the the science
work you're talking there of Michael
Faraday the British scientist in the
19th century Donna I think the point I
was trying to make that if somebody came
to me and said what we need is a better
tool to cut an eyeball back in 1985
until we understood that the work that
we did actually change how we understand
that the atom and the light sees each
other it would have always stayed a
thermal process because it was the only
way we understood it and now it's not a
thermal process and so this is you can
ask for someone to have a cutting tool
but Ann we couldn't have come up with it
from being asked to do it at least this
would not have been the waiting I would
by accident and maybe relate the story
because laser eye surgery which was
cited in your prize has been one of the
benefits along with them how to tackle
space debris as well as nuclear waste
reducing its radioactive properties by
hundreds of thousands of years but it
came about by accident and that was in
Gerard's lab it's exactly what we what
we were talking about yes in we were
doing fundamental science but is 20 to
understand the interaction of the light
matter ok which is very complicated
things and and when my student you know
aligning the laser or got the laser in
his eye we took you know to the to the
ophthalmologist look at the look at the
students and the eye of the student and
then he say wow you got hit with the
laser indeed
but what kind of laser do you have and
the student said you know why are asking
me these questions and say well because
your damage is perfect and now you have
millions of people each year you know
getting your eye fixed by the
femtosecond so Donna Strickland in the
end your approach to pure fundamental
science was actually very useful yes but
it took ten this is our ten-year gap
there that's you can't necessarily hope
for an application right away and I'm
not saying that I don't agree with you
you can come at it from all sides and
you have to have everybody working on
all levels of it but sometimes I get a
little frustrated that the science that
just doesn't have an absolute
application seen down the road does not
ever get the million dollar funding and
maybe it would be nice if people would
just sometimes say I have a million
dollars for you to do whatever the heck
you might want to do
[Music]
[Applause]
Jonah's written dates be much remarked
upon that you're the third only the
third ever female physicist to win the
Nobel Prize and the first in 55 years
and you have talked about an implicit
bias against female scientist scientists
you were told when to when you're
interested in science and math these
were boys subjects I was told by a high
school teacher that at some point and I
was stunned and I thought that was such
a ridiculous thing to say that and I
couldn't say that to a teacher so I
turned to my friend who was a male and
said do you know you're into girls
subjects because he was so good at
English we're starting at I think most
institutions to understand and be taught
about implicit bias and the fact that
you might not think you're prejudiced
against one type of thing or another but
that somehow your background idea is
coming to play and that you have to
learn to get around that and so I think
with effort things keep changing and I'm
sure it won't be another fifty five
years Francis Arnold I mean wonder if
you would want to comment on this the
fact is if you just look at overall 95%
of all Nobel Prizes since it was started
in 1901 have been won by men is that
because you think the women are doing
the work and not being recognized or
they're just not being encouraged in
sufficient numbers to go into sciences
well in the past of course the the
numbers were very low and that that is
certainly reflected in the dearth of
women women winning Nobel prizes but I
agree with Donna that's going to change
and it's going to change fast because
women are doing science at the highest
levels and they make up 50% of the most
brilliant minds so and they're doing
science now so I'm looking forward to a
much better future professor Liu
actually your supervisor not only was
your student a female than Cher
surprised with you but your supervisor
was a supervisor
yes I did at that time I didn't think in
anything wrong about it or weird about
it because that may be because of French
except I think we have historically
you know always accepted woman I mean
you see Marie Curie for instance nice
exactly and usually you know when we
were going to a meeting to a conference
you are saying you were seeing a
scientist and often often a Fang you
know it was she was a flange you know if
you saw a woman yes it's changing fast
in part because in the biological
sciences at least over half the students
now are women I think in the medical
field certainly doctors it's it's
halfway or even more than that it's
don't worry about white men don't do it
well come to the end of this discussion
just want to ask you all and you've
reached what some regard as the ultimate
accolade receiving a Nobel Prize what
next George Smith well I'm retired so I
bought long since a thought of what next
I took a couple months retirement from
my retirement just now but I guess the
first one thing that's next is I have to
learn that I don't know everything the
way Nobel Prize laureates are encouraged
to think of but my future is really not
specifically in science but maybe in the
collectivity professor no well for me I
don't think anything is going to change
because what I like is right science and
so it's not because I get this Nobel
Prize but I'm going to change my habits
I think on the contrary I think I'm
going to do it better because now of
course you know when when someone with
another prize speaks people listen you
know and so I'm I'm going to try to do
the same thing but better
don't know what else what next
well I'll continue to work on the things
I've worked on recently which are
climate change but actually I began
working in much the same area Paul Romer
did his work which was on technology and
technology has brought has been miracles
I mean we're living here rather than
caves because of technology but just as
economic growth has side effects that
dark side effects like climate change I
also think technology has dark sides and
I particularly am concerned about its
dark side on our institutions on our
democracies and I'm particularly
concerned about the role of social media
like Facebook or on our institutions
professor Jim Allison well I think
that's we've shown now that we could
cure some patients with cancer I have
the goal of trying to get that rate it's
close to a hundred percent I possibly
can and and there's many different kinds
of cancers we have and I'm hoping that
the surprise again well give me out a
bit of a soapbox first it's shown that
immunotherapy works which everybody was
skeptical about before and hopefully
I'll help bring more funding and help us
get the work done but also to other
things that may not be so obvious what I
miss - I'll let patients you know have
hope that their you know death of cancer
diagnosis of cancer isn't necessarily a
death sentence and you know they can
actually some at least can be to be
cured and the second and the final one
is that I think I hope that the prize
will inspire more patients to
participate in clinical trials which
will help us progress faster professor
tasuku's quandary yeah so I know
actually two dreams one is to get a
Nobel Prize but the other one is the age
shoot in my golf game
beautiful Frances all well after this
week I have to say my immediate goal is
to get some sleep but I'm very excited
about the future of evolution and how I
have one good idea in the 1980s and I've
worked it ever since but there are such
amazing things that we can use to move
into the future and the combination with
machine learning and artificial
intelligence is a frontier that I'm
going to ride to the next level
Jonah Strickland well I mean I have to
say that my life has been turned upside
down because of a Nobel Prize and
everybody wants to hear from a Nobel
Prize so I'm already booking into 2020
at this point but I agree with George
that some some of the people that
actually want to hear from me all of a
sudden are the politicians and I do have
some public policy work that is not
about my own research but about
photonics in general and how important
it is and I'm getting that opportunity
to speak to government leaders and and
try to explain that and in particular we
think photonics has a huge role to play
in environmental measurement and
monitoring so we can try to do all these
things for climate control but we have
to know that we've done them and so we
think photonics has a huge role for that
and so that's one of the things that I'm
out there pushing in public policy and
Paul Raymond we get to bring 14 people
to the events here at the Nobel ceremony
and I brought along professor Caroline
Weber and her parents and my family and
we got married this week while we were
here in
looking forward I'm looking forward to a
honeymoon where we can turn off the
phones turn off the devices just just
read with joyous note double
congratulations to you Paul Romer
renewed congratulations to all of you
that's all from this year's Nobel minds
thank you very much indeed to all the
Nobel laureates to our audience and of
course to you wherever you're watching
in the world from me Zainab Byrd are we
and the rest of the noble minds team
from the concert hall here in Stockholm
Sweden goodbye
[Applause]
[Music]
you